Maurice jones-drew my good friend for a
long time running the rock at the
Jacksonville Jaguars and then the
Oakland Raiders and then joining the NFL
Network and he's been a Rams radio
analyst for a few years now back here
kind enough on the show first of two
Friday appearances in a row you were the
scible as well we can't wait I'm have my
kids there though so I love that kids
are welcome all right anywhere that
fantastic bring the family will be no
snowballs or anything so you got to
worry about because this is cool too I
mean you're you're going to the Super
Bowl you're calling this Super Bowl mjd
I mean this is this is like for a
professional broadcaster this is a
pinnacle so congrats on thank you it was
crazy because I was trying to get my
kids out of school and you know you
really don't know until you know that
was he's Sunday so I called in Monday
made my wife and we know put in so we
can get some homework I forget what they
call it but they you take it with you
because my parents my mom lives there my
sister lives in Atlanta so they'll stay
with them for a little bit but the
school was a little hesitant on letting
them go and so I had to tell them I
listen they're gonna go regardless then
oh this is huge so won't you get McVeigh
to write him a plea you know an excuse
letter he has a lot going on it means so
McVeigh you could write it for him and
just shove it in front of him and say
just sign it yeah I probably should that
for you like that I think he would but
the principal saw how big it was and was
like it's all good okay that's great so
you know what does this school think
think think they are like educators
whatever your kids are gonna learn this
week they're never going to remember
they're gonna remember for the rest of
their lives spending a week with their
dad at the Super Bowl well I think
that's what the principal said so that's
what I was like you are just gonna
you're just gonna be that parent at
school
nobody wants around because I speak
logic and truth I don't think there's a
lot of that at some schools so you know
I told this story earlier this week
about the flight that I was on with Kara
Henderson now Kara Henderson Sneed my
longtime friend good friend from ESPN
and then we helped launch NFL Network
together she was on the first-ever total
access fascinating than enough she was
pregnant with her now
high-school-aged son interviewing Tom
Brady at the Super Bowl in Houston after
they beat the Carolina Panthers and now
here we go
watching the Rams she's now married to
less need any rate she said let's you
know she if you want to fly back from CI
game in Seattle the Thursday night game
in 2016 and I went through the Rams sure
enough sat next to her and that plane
flight was a morgue they got blown out
by three scores Jared Goff has still
been winless as a starting quarterback
they had fired Jeff Fisher earlier in
the week a short week it was John fossil
now the special teams coordinator and
the plane rot flight was a morgue Chris
across the aisle for me was Maurice
jones-drew no light and DeMarco far who
does the broadcast with you as well st.
Louis Rams ampion DeMarco far he was
right next to you nobody on that plane
in a million years thought that you were
anywhere near a Super Bowl 36 games from
Super Bowl if I told you on that flight
that you're 36 games away from Super
Bowl not only that though the rest of
the league would be trying to mimic what
the Rams were cooking what if I told you
that that I probably would have been
like I appreciate all the the kindness
to pick us up but well you know probably
none at that situation you you just
never know what was gonna happen after
after that game but you know I think the
Rams brass had a great job identifying
coach McVeigh and the story behind that
is that they didn't think that he might
not have been they were like well he may
not be ready now but when he is ready we
won't be a have a chance to get him and
so they took a real big chance on him
and it's worked out and you know he's
addressed some needs that they really
had at the left tackle position receiver
position challenge all those players to
be better and and it's it's been a story
ever since what does he do I mean cuz
again I did my top ten storylines for
Super Bowl 53 he's one and two story
line number two is him versus Belichick
but number one is anything McVeigh what
does he do when you see this in person
what does he do for the Rams that is a
difference maker well the first time I
met him he was like hey Maurice let's go
out to dinner let's talk
and I was like that's this is you know
granted he's younger than I am but he
was kind of like it was like he was cool
he's one of the guy he's like that
friend that everyone follows in a way
where he's gonna tell you what's right
and wrong but also he's gonna have
you're gonna enjoy those moments and I
think everyone's embraced him and after
that game against the Saints you saw
like Michael Bracco's running to a mare
and down all the guys who tell him thank
you because he's holding him to a higher
standard he saw something that they
didn't see themselves and he's able to
pull it out without yelling at you and
without degrading you and and I guess in
that way and so it's been it's been a
crazy ride he's talking a guy I talked
to Todd a lot every week and you know
obviously I didn't have his best game
against the Saints and you know
sometimes you just wake up and not you
don't have a bad game but McVeigh was
there the whole time like we're gonna
get you going we're gonna get you going
and not only did Todd not make he scored
a touchdown but there was some huge
plays in the game where he didn't have
the ball where he picked up some blitzes
to allow Jared golf to slide or big
throws to Brandon cooks or other guys
get open and that's and that's what it's
about and so you know he praises guys
even when you don't do well with the
ball when you do it without it and those
are the plays they need so you know he I
don't know like the culture he's created
they're like it's hard to emulate and
the things they do but he's done a
phenomenal job
he sure has and he's in the Super Bowl
it's a 33 year old head coach he just
turned 33 just this week Maurice
jones-drew here in the Honda inside a
report all right what is with Todd
Gurley what is happening is he hurt he's
hurt I don't think he's hurt um to be
honest with the end and I may be wrong I
think we saw a great he did a great job
in Dallas sometimes you get in the
playoffs oh it's it's who's hotter and
CJ Anderson was the hotter guy I
remember playing the Baltimore Ravens on
Monday night and I don't know what it
was I just kept fumbling I think I'm
like four times and it was just like I'd
change my gloves I'd wash my hands I
went in at halftime I took a shower to
try to get whatever was on me off you
see sometimes you wrote you wake up on
about you know wrong side of the bed and
it's just not your day but that's that
that's one time I think has happened for
Todd and so I don't I don't I expect him
to come back in the Superbowl and be
able to be the guy that he's always been
and play the way he's played if he's not
hurt what's he doing on the pike
what's the stationery I'm trying to stay
warm because remember you're on the
sidelines you're sitting there you're
not you're not moving you're not doing
anything so that's not Gurley the og
okay
the MVP at the midway point of this
course I mine okay
the guy who essentially if you had to
point to one guy on the offensive side
of the ball who is who is responsible
for making sure that the Rams had a bye
week Todd Gurley correct up we know who
the other guy is on the other side of
the ball and Aaron Donald how is he now
suddenly the guy that just can't get the
burst can't get to the hole and that CJ
Anderson looks so much more vibrant
coming off of the couch well let's
remember the Saints had the number two
rush defense to so it wasn't a CJ
Anderson ran well but they didn't break
a hundred yards they didn't really have
the explosive gains they wanted in the
running game but it opened up their
passing game Todd's a different back and
so when you watch the Dallas Cowboys all
right Riley TV go back to Dallas where
you saw the explosiveness he put its
foot in the ground he made cuts he made
people miss that's the tight just
couldn't do it this week and so again
sometimes it's just it's just not your
day like it's hard to say that to be
like in the NFC Championship game it's
not your day but people have bad games
so it just so happened that it was Todd
Gurley this week and hopefully that it
doesn't carry on but I got a chance to
talk to him after and you know I I saw
his I saw his his the interview at the
end of the game and I could I've been
there before you're like look I played
like trash and it takes a lot because
you are a guy that is expected a ton of
but I reminded him like there's no way
that they are here where you are without
you so it's not like you get you're
afforded a bad day now it's just not to
have a second one and be able to go
forward and and then and that team did a
great job of picking him up I mean CJ
Anderson came in did a great job
Robert woods Brandon cooks has a hundred
yards
Jared golfed your tight ends I mean
let's hit this here for a second with
you Maurice jones-drew
golf dropped his Huggies in this game no
questions use the Parcells phrase of
growing up some of the throws he made
were dynamite including the third down
one to help set up the game-tying field
goal I thought that game was in fact
over based on the way the
first couple of plays were going on
there first offensive set
he made a Greg Roman to his right I
thought oh god he's gonna throw it away
and now the whole seasons gonna come
down on what it was and I think it led
to the Everett
completion that was the longest
completion of the entire game I mean
that was something else right there well
did the RAM is what people don't know
the Rams are one of the top teams I want
to say if not the top team in the two
minutes situation at the end of the half
are the end of the game they always
convert for points which is huge and
that was a thing that I brought up on
our broadcast is that they excel in
these type of situations it may be it's
because Jared golfers you used to the
no-huddle from Cal when he was there
maybe it's just they perform better you
see more simple coverages in those
situations but he was able to make plays
and and those guys believed in their
system and what they do and Jared when
he throws the ball to him and again the
Gerald Everett catch and run was amazing
right you haven't seen that type of guys
are just showing up and sometimes you
need that one your best players going
down but I remember I I so it's fun I
used to train at Cal when I would
playing in the Phil and Jarrod was a
freshman and he was hurt he got hurt
after his freshman so I was banged up a
little bit and we were in the treatment
room that's where I really got to know
him there because we were doing
treatment at the same time huh and the
eight year old Jarrod golf is completely
different than the guy now what do you
mean just he didn't have the swag back
then he you know he's from Marin
Catholic so I give him that you know
North Bay is a little bit different than
East Bay and other things like that but
you know he's just real confident after
the game you know seeing him with Marcus
Pierce said I think we're not done yet
right those like that that is leadership
having a good time with his friends and
and really embracing that team and what
they have there and it's gonna be
interesting to see this game cuz I can't
wait to see it's a big-time rivalry till
I people don't know this you know Tom
Brady and everyone knows went to Sarah
high school in the Bay Area up north
where their rival is is Marin Catholic
where Jerry golf went it's a big game
man it's a lot on the line oh my god no
storyline for CSI stuff right now if I
gave you the top ten that might not even
crack the top 100 but I understand that
we're always looking to
I've a few lines of connection here got
you it goes D hi there go that's next
level right there for Maurice jones-drew
and before we turn the page Super Bowl
53 the non pass interference call right
it is going to be something discussed
next week certainly if the Commissioner
in the league does not put out a
statement this week at all essentially
saying what the obvious is and I think
Saints fans want to hear it you saw what
Benjamin Watson tweeted out although I
don't know what what would be gained out
of hey we blew it and we want to make
sure it's not we're gonna take steps to
make sure that it's not gonna happen
again but it's gonna be discussed next
week Andrew Whitworth gave us an
indication when he came in on Monday
show and he called and told the Rams are
gonna handle this it's an excuse there
was more football to be played they add
the ball they didn't score we got it
we scored we win very simple I'll say
this first of all first and foremost the
Saints fans very passionate group we
were out there before the game I mean we
were talking they were talking trash I
couldn't even get what I wanted to tell
you out because they were all over me
about it what they did feed us and they
get their create they created seafood
they had the best Hospital I've ever had
okay
what that all being said you have some
no trash the more you put this on coach
Sean Payton this is on him this is on
anyone else in that situation you're
opposed to run the ball three times kick
the field goal make them earn their
timeouts so that now you're putting the
pressure on Jared Goff and a dolphins to
go down the field with a minute or so
left
apparently Peyton did call a run play
one drew saw oh no he sucks and drew
went ahead and threw the ball on first
down it wouldn't pass option kind of
dirted it you know well that's and
that's everything in motion that led to
a why not just go for it on third and
ten and then that blue hole I have never
seen a worse blown call I mean I've seen
some bad calls have you ever seen no I
haven't but I'll say this and no number
one thing with the coaching and talking
with a lot of coaches the number one
rule is never leave it in the refs hands
never
leaving the revs hands because you never
know again we have to remember they're
human they're not perfect so human area
always can come in that in that in that
situation I don't know what he was
seeing I didn't get to see it from that
vantage point I was up high looking down
you thought a flag was coming though
right yeah I felt like a flag was coming
it didn't and it happens it granted but
that that one play doesn't change the
game let's let's talk about all the
times that the Saints got into the red
zone and kick field goals let's talk
about that the fact that they had it in
OT which we saw Tom Brady have the ball
no Tina's in the game so there was
opportunities throughout the course of
the game and I felt like they could have
taken advantage of it just wasn't that
one call and people have to stop doing
that because you know we're given we're
given you know we're teaching that it's
okay to be upset and make excuses like
no there were 60 odd minutes plus more
to be played and you can't let dwell on
those things now I don't want to say
Maurice you know what you never want
anything a day in your life and I'm
gonna bark back and say no I won four
national high school championships and I
work with you every day so it's a but I
have an opinion too and I've never
played in the NFL you have so we all and
fans all do too
but again I'm just wondering what the
league's approach is gonna be here
because there's anything the
commissioners state of the state address
is gonna happen next Thursday he's gonna
make public appearances in Atlanta you
know we're there is going to be a
question posed of the league what do you
think and what are you going to do all
you can say is that we can try to
improve that because it's not like Roger
Goodell made that call it's not like how
River I made this so whoever made that
call you're gonna obviously sanction him
on that or whose job that was and then
say we have to learn from it moving
forward it's the same with the Tuck rule
you don't think that I was sick watching
the Raiders beat the Patriots in New
England with that with the fumble and
there was no explanation that it was
just like oh this is a rule that it
hasn't been used in ever ever right and
we're gonna use it this time so it just
is like one of those things that you
have to live with it and there's other
and there's other plays that have
happened throughout the course of our
our history of this game that have
changed different dynamics it is what it
is it's that's what makes our gang
special that's why it's that's why it's
always gonna be and I we were talking
about the Lakers and the Warriors I'm a
big Warriors fan and Spurs I love I used
to love minded you know blue back in the
day
the difference between NBA MLB hockey
although they play seven games seriously
you can afford to mess up you can't do
that in football and that's what makes
football the greatest game is that you
have to be on your best one time it's
all you get is one chance you get
nothing else and so I can understand why
people are upset but I also don't
understand why you just keep going back
to that one play when you won the coin
toss in OT and you should have won
Maurice jones-drew a few more minutes
left with you here in the Honda inside a
report so McVeigh and it's also Wade
Phillips obviously together what do they
think Belichick and McDaniels are
cooking up here to prepare golf and also
for them to know what to do with Brady
what do you think well I think
defensively coach Weaver has to be ready
for inside pressure if you look at the
times when Jared is struggle did they've
found ways to get pressure inside you
saw the Patriots do that use lighting
stunts and things from the defensive
line at Patrick my Holmes and that's how
you get sacks on most quarterbacks if
you can get inside pressure so the
offensive line has to be prepared for
those type of games yeah there and there
was one time where the inside pressure
forced mahomes right into the spy
exactly he made a dynamite crazy-ass our
man yeah throw anyway right I don't
think I don't and I'm not you know I
think my home is probably the most
talented quarterback we have in this
league so you want to make sure that you
protect your quarterback and put him in
his best or put him out where he can be
at his best but the other thing is
they're gonna blitz you and they're
gonna try to get the ball out of
Jarrod's hands quickly so you have to
have you know built in hot routes for
that defensively for the Rams I think
you had to be ready to stop the run I
know that first drive against uh the
Chiefs the pagers ran the ball at eight
or nine times in the fifteen michelle
has been diamond a dynamite man James
Devlin I keep talking about him you know
a fullback what it brings to that team
on the touchdown to go ahead before they
went in OT he hit Eric Berry and then
kind of like drove him into the ground
creating more space that's something
that a fullback is able to bring and the
Rams rarely see that if you look at the
Saints game they rarely played with the
full-back they play with two tight ends
instead of bringing in their fullback so
that's just a different aspect that they
have to get used to and try to dive in
but the Rams defense has done a great
job of stopping the run the last
games they've only allowed 100 under 100
yards rushing or something crazy like
that so I think they're up for the task
and you know you have guys that are
played in that New England Patriots
system which is nice where the pages
don't have a guy who's played in this
Shaw McVeigh system subtly Brian yeah
Talib you have Brandon cooks obviously
of last year so you can lean on those
guys and see kind of get some
information from them and go out there
and you know I think everyone talks
about you know you have to play a
perfect game against the Patriots you
know you just have to play your game you
just have to go out there and do your
job I know Bill Belichick says it all
the time you don't think so
you got to play perfect game SD Ford
that's my guy to I not create you can't
do second chances you can't do a pre
snap penalty to turn second and five in
a second intent no no you can't do a pre
snap penalty that turns third and ten
for them into third and five you can't
figure out who the 12th man is to come
off the field the last second we do some
sort of crazy as special teams run the
regular team back out but they almost
got Kansas City on in the AFC champion
game and when there's a loose ball on
the field you got to get it go get it
don't let it sit there with that well
I'll say this that's just off the top my
head
the Rams they went out and they they
really went out and got guys defensively
they helped for this like in Dom because
Souza done a great job stopping the run
Aaron Donald's didn't phenomenal job
stopping the run Michael brokers as well
and they said they they have to tell him
the pieces to do it it comes down to
making sure that your guys are prepared
to be a to do their best make sure
you're healthy which they are they're
one of the healthiest teams in the
league right now and and if they can
keep going and imagine if if Todd goes
out there and has a day that we're used
to it's gonna be tough
Maurice jones-drew do you want to stay
one more segment we can I don't have a
problem with it one more segment I want
to talk about the Warriors with you oh
yes I might take on or if you heard that
in there and oh it's gonna be tough to
get to get with him I used to be a
warrior I used to have season tickets
when Baron Davis and the guys were there
they take a present got up a little bit
so I try to okay Maurice jones-drew here
on the Rich Eisen show one more segment
with him and your phone calls also still
to come 844 204 riches the number 2 tile
welcome back to the show Maurice
jones-drew is here as well and joined me
and on Friday in particular Maurice
jones-drew
on our set in Atlanta for Super Bowl
week we're gonna be on the campus there
at Turner it's gonna be a blade a blast
just a great time we're gonna have JB
Smoove in studio all tuesdays program
dan patrick kicks off our our our show
with us on monday after he's done with
his show there in atlanta he's gonna
join us and we've got a live studio
audience as well so come out and join us
rich in atlanta com get your free
tickets for Super Bowl week in Atlanta
rich in Atlanta dot-com or East
jones-drew still here so bring your kids
right yo yeah they're coming so you're
gonna have a posse you're gonna have no
no because my my sister's gonna have
work I think my mom is I stay at home
with her my young but I'll bring my two
boys with me Paul question brought to
you by Tru car when it comes to selling
or trading in your car you need to make
good choices and with true car you've
got a star on your roster so when you're
ready to sell or trade in your car check
out true car disclaimer is that cash
offer the true cash offer is not
available in all Aries Christopher what
do you have guys we had a great NFL
season but what will you remember most
from this past year patrick mahomes the
officiating Brady and Drew Brees ageless
Seasons Baker Mayfield or Pittsburgh
Steelers drama
what would you remember out of all of
that all those who I know what my answer
would be I think probably Pittsburgh
really because it's Le'Veon Bell started
levy honest with him you share an agent
right yeah we do you tell me I was
training right now has been training for
the last month and a half just getting
ready for the next team is he is it true
he has identified a team there's a
report out there that he's identified
the Dolphins what do you got oh I don't
I don't know that I know they were a
team early on but obviously with the
coaching change I don't know if that's
gonna be the team now okay
but it makes sense though because that's
where he trains and that's where a lot
of his support is yeah that's raised and
and then everybody made it see when he
tweeted out goodbye to Miami and wound
up playing a wreck game in Pittsburgh
everybody thought okay he's coming back
and then he did well yeah yeah he has a
house they're sad to make sure
everything was oh is that what was make
sure that
pipes weren't freezing over get the mail
you know how it is well the latest on
that is ESPN's Jeremy Fowler wrote a
heck of a piece on what
behind-the-scenes in Pittsburgh there's
all these AFC North behind-the-scenes
drama pieces on espn.com and Wickersham
on yesterday we see if we can get Jeremy
Fowler on the program later on as well
about how Tomlin's telling everybody
that that Brown is tolerable until his
results on the field are I think that's
a lot that's everyone knows every coach
it's everybody right I think that's in
every business you're gonna if so long
as someone's producing you're gonna put
up with them until they stop producing
then you'll move on to find the next
person that's just how it goes
my pick is mahomes for the poll I mean
he's just I mean just incredible just
absolutely remarkable season and is an
essential and and and is the face of the
league for the moment with the no-look
pass that's what sold Lee it's the
no-look it's the left hand it's also the
the different arm angles it's also just
what what you know where he is for the
voice it's everything
the Chiefs middle of the country and
crazy hair the headband it's the whole
pack to catch up we catch you all the
ketchup I'm a ranch guy like that like I
could put ranch on anything but ketchup
Maurice thanks for coming here I'm out
now it's time for you to go Rich's big
ketchup guy yeah really
ketchups good I will put ketchup on
everything yep I'm rich my son actually
cuz Andrews got a shirt set up in
college we get to run everything he is
in ketchup monster monster I've created
a cat monster Wow catch a monster Wow
not gonna lie yeah what do you think you
warriors I say they're gonna win 30 if
they're gonna break the record of 33
straight wins
I don't like conscience right now yeah
you know what I really don't know I just
being up there and being around a lot of
those guys who kind of all live in the
same area they're just a great group of
dudes to be honest with you they love to
play basketball but what I will say is
that a lot of people all that hate about
like oh they're getting better well
someone else could assign you know
DeMarcus Cousins
beside him that right it's not like
Kevin Durant went to free-agency he had
opportunity to pick where he wanted to
go they just had a culture there and I
think you know Steph has done a great
job of managing you know a lot of egos
and things going on and the best part
about their team is if you're hot you're
gonna get the ball and Boogie's just
it's it really is amazing I think there
was like a thing the Warriors verse the
Eastern Conference all-stars who would
win good to see you sir thank you I'll
see you in Atlanta next Friday on our
Friday show that'll be great Congrats on
calling the Super Bowl okay I'm really
thrilled for you the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience